we're on earth right now today in 2020
do blacks have it better than in the
United States
black Americans can face different forms
of discrimination and still be living in
the best place in the world for someone
of their skin color period question of
the day have you heard of this suppose
it blacks it that's occurring with black
Americans they're leaving the United
States moving back to Africa it's being
advocated by a lot of black activists do
you know anyone personally and do you
think blacks need to leave because not
me this is what they are advocating over
at Essence magazine I think we haven't
yet we have this article right here from
essence there's this increasingly sort
of common claim that black Americans can
we say blacks do what do we is this
blacks okay I feel like that's wrong and
that's what Central Americans but a lot
of them are an African American they
don't like it some of you read me the
riot act when I said African American
blacks coloreds
to get away from racism this is what
they wrote about in essence magazine
even saying that this is a viable
solution right now it's being suggested
by black activists under the rule of
Trump so just give you a feel by the way
for the author of this article it's kind
of gone viral and it's been echoed by
places I think with the New York Times
and maybe was Huffington Post Kristen
Kirsten Christin Kirsten got a thing
about that savaii I want to make sure I
get her name right she claims it in
America black Americans will go with
that that sort of feathers it up black
in there yeah took half from African
American half from blacks black
Americans that they're supposedly living
in occupied territory and that the
police are given them specifically under
Trump the right to kill them with
impunity that's part of the premise
let's hear from her we talk about what's
happened since Ferguson you know what's
happened since then
slave patrols
I play black people back to plantation
when the crime was not the humanizing
institutional violence of slavery it was
actually people seeking freedom and they
were meant to bring them back so again
we're talking about occupied territories
we were talking about oppressed
communities we're talking about
militarized police departments who have
been given so right
the kill with impunity and it happens
over and over and over again does your
character have a hair net no wait we all
played guess who right yeah okay I
really should get an actually in the
roster and then a ferret apparently
start using it oh look what happened
here this whole thing just shut down
thank you thank you nothing you can run
prompter do you think that Sean Hannity
has to do this know exactly what is
written for him by somebody else yeah
yeah ah screams okay so that's Kristen
savelii let's take a look at some of
these claims though that I think are
pretty important one of the claims okay
and you see this in the article not all
from that clip there the founding
fathers they encoded dehumanization and
oppression into the Constitution to
preserve their privileges they're all
direct quotes from essence I highly
recommend that you go read them here's
the truth that's bullcrap okay
the entire world employed slavery by the
way not just african-americans okay but
sorry about that
sorry about that Amtrak thanks you the
point is all of human civilization
practiced slavery since the beginning of
time to one degree earn a lot of the
world still does we ended it and so this
is something that just shouted out a lot
and so people accept it is true the
founding fathers were they were actually
very troubled deeply troubled by the
idea of slavery and they were already
taking steps to try and pave the way to
change the course of history and slavery
long before most of the people were
thinking about it okay so the
continuation of slavery was actually one
of the primary gripes against King
George before we declared independence I
have a quote here from Thomas Jefferson
King George the third
the thirsty be confused has waged cruel
war against human nature itself
violating its most sacred rights of life
and liberty in the person's of a distant
people who never offended him
captivating and carrying them into
slavery in another hemisphere or to
incur a miserable death in their
transportation thither that's always a
good word I'm determined to keep open a
market where men should be bought and
sold he has prostituted his negative for
suppressing every legislative attempt to
prohibit or to restrain this extra
crippled commerce that is he has opposed
efforts to prohibit the slave trade
pretty clear now again keep in mind
something that was not only legal but it
was enforced at this point right now
let's say that there's an unjust law you
disagree with often you'll hear people
say this to the right they go well if
you disagree with this taxation why
aren't you actually viola or why aren't
pro-life people being more violet with
abortion clinics because that's not what
we advocate we believe in working within
the law we believe in respecting the
rule of law even as we try to change it
through the system of law that we have
so let's keep that in context Benjamin
Franklin he said a disposition to
abolish slavery prevails in North
America that many of Pennsylvanians have
set their slaves at liberty and that
even the Virginia assembly have
petitioned the king for permission to
make a law for preventing the
importation of more into that colony
this request however will probably not
be granted as their former laws of that
kind of always been repealed now let's
go to some of the personal actions again
read the essence magazine is predicated
on the idea that our founding fathers
were pro-slavery and wanted to continue
it George Washington he made it that his
phrase could be sleeve his phrase phrase
I had a struggle yeah his slaves could
be freed I'm talking like her it's a
continuum
he wanted his slaves to be freed upon
his death it was it was illegal by the
way to do so while he was alive
Jefferson by the way he maintained a
strong anti-slavery stance throughout
his entire life by his death state laws
had stiffened so much it was pretty much
impossible for him to free the slaves as
Washington had but Washington did that
upon his death he freed his slaves
another claim she makes there is no
corner in the United States where it's
safe to be black here's the truth bows
not even close no place in the United
States where it's safe to be black Plano
Texas Burlington Vermont Cedar Rapids
take your pick miss guess who as a
matter of fact do you know what do you
know were black you're black Americans
are safer in general in the United
States can you guys take a guess as to
where black Americans are safer in this
country nowhere tell us what is it
they're safer in white areas
predominantly white areas in black areas
as are far less likely to be the victim
of crime for the hands of white
Americans then fellow black Americans I
take no joy in that that's a statistical
reality but I won't I bet you won't
you're not gonna hear that on the SPLC
latest hate crime email newsletter
instead they'll be talking about proud
boys moving into a bar fight with some
guys in Bend
around their face as to black Americans
being safer in white areas all the afro
mention cities Kate they're all safer
for black Americans and predominantly
black cities you can look at the list of
safest cities in the country by the way
for both white and black Americans you
can look at those stats then if you
wanted to find the least safe cities for
black Americans you'd have to take that
list scroll down keep scrolling keep
scrolling the lycée yep that would be
Detroit in st. Louis yeah and I don't
know which I think Detroit is worse but
you guys have it pretty bad yeah st.
Louis's it's it's this is the part where
you argue for the check and you say no
no st. Louis is worse but yeah st.
Louis's definitely down we all know and
a good point is that's not a race thing
but I'll tell you what is where you
could attribute something here to race
you could attribute the voting block and
not black Americans because you look at
the changes in the voting bloc under
Donald Trump but the activists like this
writer for Essence magazine and like the
activists who've tried to speak for the
black community to install is's that
have systematically destroyed them the
problem is a lot of these people are not
really representative of black Americans
go ask black Americans right now if you
could pay for a free ticket for them to
go to any country outside the United
States to live forevermore no one would
take it so someone like this let's be
really not a cleaner she speak for most
black Americans nor do the BuzzFeed
boldly lesbians we need to be really
clear about this I feel like black
people in the media unfortunately are
often represented by social justice
where your leftist and not the true
average black American voice who is
probably the moderate base of the
Democratic Party today let's be clear
you may run into the occasional let's
say white racist farmer in Cedar Rapids
I don't know I'm not familiar with Cedar
Rapids if there's one farmers oh listen
don't man I don't know let's call it
your neighbor but a black American is
far safer say in Burlington Vermont or
Frisco Texas or Cedar Rapids than
Chicago it's not even close and the good
news is black Americans you can move to
any of those places and you can still
get B et yeah what about the own network
I I'm not entirely familiar with the old
network but I've never watched it that
being said I'm sure there's a package
available for that see you all the white
people they get to watch their Matlock
and you black Americans persons you can
watch your your family matters or your
mo
Ruffini big tech has something for
everyone by the way it's another Haitian
belle if you're subscribed because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
these days hit all notifications and we
also the channel Crowder bits up on
YouTube which is ironically I think
monetizing this channel is not don't
even try to mug club were funded by mugs
not a foreign caliphate here's another
claim the term blacks it is used and she
uses this in her article in essence and
talks about it the term black suit is
used to describe black Americans leaving
the country due to racism to live
somewhere else and this is important
because this person is brought on to
television programs we can talk about
the black sit so this term is used and
what does that assume it assumes that
it's actually going on a black sit which
is coined by activists it's not
statistically there is no black sit
funny story actually funny you should
ask viewer who I can't speak with but I
can spy on your webcam because you never
sticky note or use Express VPN under
President Donald Trump the single
fastest growing group of legal
immigrants is again with a number of
African immigrants growing at a rate of
almost 50% one 2010 to 2018 and in
Monroe we're just Obama's half-brothers
so a lot of families don't even know all
that much big family that's screams of
his father paternity test from his
father so by the way in this country
immediately following this is important
of the abolition of slavery some free
slaves were offered travel back to
Africa where there's a designated plot
of land for the people who wanted to
leave partially funded by Congress most
freed slaves were they were not thrilled
with it yeah they decided you know what
you keep your one-way here's another
claim this is from the article according
the SPLC you hear this a lot the number
of hate groups has risen truth very much
so the SPLC includes churches some of
which are think are absolutely at least
half black churches and groups like the
proud voice which is a glorified
drinking club there aren't more actual
hate groups they've just brought in
their definitions second a review using
the same methodology okay we're talking
about here is these widely touted hate
crime studies right here's a surprise
here comes from cold-water it showed
that clinton's rallies were linked to an
even greater rise in
hate crime so neither the methodology is
flawed or Hillary is 100% neo-nazi and
she just saw her she has I just stopped
a look at her stomach at the valium pen
calm her ass now it's just remarkable
that Hillary Clinton is Edie furlong in
American history yet I don't believe
that's the case I don't think that
Hillary Clinton having a rally where
nobody shows up or Elizabeth Warren is
equivalent to someone being curb-stomped
in a hate crime but if we're using your
standards
you're worse yeah okay here's the
article right it goes on to cite that
black Americans living in places like
Ghana and Qatar that they should be
places where black Americans maybe
should move to to achieve a higher
standard of living and less
discrimination and they argue that some
black people have moved to these country
the truth about all its complete bull
crap the quality of life is far far
lower and places like guitar despite
what clock boy tells you and they still
have indentured servitude to this day
what happened the slavery argument I
know the Qatari everything called
sponsorship laws okay
sponsors can I want to make sure I get
this right cancel workers residency
permits prevent them from changing
employers deny them permission to leave
the country and they can report them to
the police if they do so they are
similar laws in the UAE other countries
in the Gulf state by the way women in
prison in Qatar while we're not just
talking about people different races
women sentenced for being raped
sentenced to prison for being raped I
want to make sure them class is not
hyperbole at all an actual quote a Court
handed down a suspended one year
imprisonment sentence for engaging in
extramarital sex and deported her
it also sentence the man accused of
raping her with 100 lashes for having
extramarital sex and forty lashes for
drinking alcohol so she and this is
what's important not just that she was
punished for being raped they
acknowledge that she was raped because
they punched they punished the man for
raping her but he was punished less
severely than the woman who was raped
and forty percent of that same
punishment was just because he drank
alcohol right exactly just like do those
like I don't know transitive property
raping is if you drink two bottles of
alcohol right not much worse it's the
equivalent of rape listen I just want to
figure out my risk reward ratio here
if I rape er I will be punished about
two shots of Jagermeister
okay okay that seems like a fair trade
forty lashes alright okay this is going
to hurt so something else blacks it that
didn't get too dark I don't like this
the segment is dark I he's a little bit
talking about this I hate that I have to
acknowledge someone who's a leftist
activist claiming to speak for black
Americans telling black Americans they
should leave this country because people
like us want to harm black Americans
without impunity it is just mind-numbing
to me and you know what that does that
breeds more H hatred with young black
Americans if they see their people in
charge saying at all time they're going
to believe that people like us hate
black Americans and want to harm we
don't want that we want to see that for
anybody
they set examples of blacks living in
Egypt Vietnam so let's go the average
yearly income in a place like Vietnam is
$2,300 for Ghana
2,100 Egypt you up at a little bit
$2,800 that's annual income so let's get
this straight
this author and proponents of the black
sit movement and the people on the media
who hosts them in their little you know
three sectional views despite them being
in the same studio this author and these
people they're advising blacks to move
to places not only where slavery is
effectively still practiced but where
the yearly income is less than three
thousand dollars a year right well the
median yearly income in the United
States has increased more than four
thousand dollars under Trump it's
increased more than the total salary
total income of people in these
countries and I get it but if you go
over there where are you gonna buy your
sweet cakes where will she get those
hoop earrings and yeah no I yes exactly
I don't know I assume I assume that
they're they can probably steal them
from an indentured servant
yeah that's exactly it by the way that's
humanizing those are shower curtain
rings a lot of people don't know she's
resourceful recycling oh man good for
the environment so I think you will see
this narrative by the way we do have to
get going to the Ash Wednesday I think
you'll see this narrative increasing as
we go into the election especially by
the way if Bloomberg is still in the
race because the argument on race will I
think it'll become even more heated if
it's if it's Bloomberg if it's if it's
Pete but gig expect more accusations the
argument all center around homophobia
just like remember everyone who voted
against Obama was branded a racist and
then that switched to sexist overnight
when Hillary Clinton was running
if if the gay Alfred E Newman look-alike
secures a nomination then they're gonna
play the gay card for Pete but cake but
I think those are more sexism and
homophobia they're more like seasonal
they're more seasonal right like
pumpkins fiber statistics the race card
is always the ace up their sleeve even
the race card is that is like the star
on the menu that this is chef's
recommendation all the time so here's my
pre-emptive question let me ask you this
genuine question where on earth right
now today in 2020 do blacks have it
better than in the United States let me
be clear is there some discrimination of
course to what degree that's a
conversation and it's one that I think
that we should have that's where it's a
productive conversation are their
individual racists absolutely
quarterback Gerardus proof
slavery was awful of course right god I
have to be really clear we have to say
this 20 times the white person if you're
even touching sorry what's your opinion
on slavery was terrible was awful don't
make me have to repeat myself so someone
cut to that of context you're my lawyer
you're gonna have to be in my defense
team you don't want those kinds of hours
slavery got it after we abolish slavery
in the United States it was still awful
in the continent of Africa and it's
still awful to this day in most of in
parts of Africa it's worse but no about
forget it still worse than the United
States but see all of these things all
the above can be true black Americans
can face different forms of
discrimination and still be living in
the best place in the world for someone
of their skin color period hope you
enjoyed this clip if you don't these are
the ABCs of me baby you can just click
Next video and put it in double speed of
course search doesn't necessarily work
subscriptions notifications don't
necessarily work just bookmark this page
chicken we do a new video every single
day except for Sunday and if you don't
want this content to disappear join one
club at Ladder with credit comm slash
mug club it's only $69 if your student
Feder interactive military and if you
don't you know listen I I don't want to
say that you're hell bound but it that
doesn't look good for you